hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and in today's video we have a new
20 20 Souls like action RPG available on
PC Xbox and Playstation coming out a lot
earlier than you think and a possible
way to access a beta code for it all in
today's video so as always like to be if
you do enjoy subscribe before new now
let's get into today's video so this is
a game made by a publisher called play
stack who seems to have published into
small indie games and mobile games but
also seems to be directed by a newly
built studio which I have some of the
main heads of the company being Andrew
McLennan Murray Anton Gonzalez and
vitality bugger off some of these guys
have worked on the recent Call of Duty
games and others have worked on ghosts
of Tsushima and the movie Elita battle
angel this game was formerly known as
dungeon Haven and is now called mortal
shell judging from the artwork it's
going to be a very gritty and realistic
looking game as much as it can be but
there's definitely going to be some
sci-fi elements and armor weapons
assumed to be bosses and it's world
building
speaking of said world building the
trailer seems to feature in many
different areas like snow mountains deep
chasms and giant Sun struck in fantasy
worlds other artworks seem to be
presuming lis our character fighting
other beings like with this guy with the
cage on his head another wheeled tail
and pale-looking creatures and others
being a mysterious shadow figure and a
giant looking being with weapons so now
that that gist has been over with the
artwork I want to discuss some of what's
happening in the trailer and then also
discuss some of the blurbs on their
website to give us a lot more info of
what we're really seeing in this
announcement trailer first up is a brief
look at some of the worlds that the
creatures of this game will be
inhabiting and probably where we're
inevitably going to be going through
within the game there's going to be
massive towers forests caves and lots of
different terrain here the main in the
trailer says you are different untouched
by false truths will you pry these gifts
from the unwilling over you let them rot
and then eventually there's some music
going in and then it cuts to saying
bring the glands back to me throughout
the trailer we can get a look at some of
the bigger enemies for suma bleah some
of the bosses and smaller feeder
well and also that very beginning part
when he says bring the glans back to me
it's that pale creature again at shoving
his hand through somebody's chest and
pulling out what seems to be some sort
of vital organ
after some nice look at the beautiful
combat that this game has next is the
character getting hit with a huge
downward slam and gets it knocked out or
changed back into that pale creature
leaving an empty shell of what the other
body he seemed to be in was and later
the voice comes back and says an empty
shell flesh and instinct without any
purpose as someone grabs someone else
we'll go into a bit more of what this is
later but just know that this seems to
be one of the unique possessed mechanics
within the game and it seems to be the
main basis of the games mechanics where
you possess other people's bodies the
trailer then shows off the game's combat
with two-handed swords one-handed
weapons even some weird-looking combos
where you can come out of your body back
into the pale body again and attack
other enemies or one where you can
freeze your entire body to stone so that
the attacks bounce off leaving the
opponent for a counter-attack as well
some arcane magic where at this moment
seems to just be Fire and Ice but
there's probably a lot more that this
trailer hasn't shown us now going over
the website we have some blurbs to bring
up and the first part reads reawaken
your struggle mortal shell is a deep
action RPG that tests your sanity and
resilience in a shattered world combat
is strategic deliberate and unforgiving
and Ardie from what you've seen from the
trailer this is why I mentioned it to be
a Souls like game in the very beginning
I understand that Dark Souls isn't the
only game with a lock on camera and roll
quite the contrary
but still players understand the term
Souls like and I can already see how it
can be called that of course that's not
a shots of the game but some people like
similarity so that they can tell if a
current game that they're looking at
piques their interest based off of their
gaming history next says possessed Lost
warriors the anima of defeated warriors
are yours to discover inhabit these
mortal shells and open your
understanding to their unique masteries
of combat as I said before it seems to
be an incredibly unique combat system of
taking enemy's weapons and masteries as
your own now for how this works and
depth we really don't understand it yet
but it could mean that you could take
the first enemy you see and keep it
forever our others going to be better
than other enemies can you possess
bosses and how can you learn these
combat moves without having to pause the
game and read some weapon combo list
when you get the possession from what I
can piece together though it seems to be
that this pale creature is actually us
in our starting form and we can possess
dead enemies so we can become them thus
as the Post said learning unique
masteries of combat and as that one part
in the trailer showed maybe too much
damage to the body can cause it to be
too weak for us to use and we get shot
out of it maybe everything in the game
was once a pale creature and now it's
just a bunch of other bodies being taken
at their leisure but who knows some of
the enemies seem to be very different
with some having something inside of
them like weapons I'm using magic in
different ways of arcane arts and it'll
be really incredible to see how this
plays out in the real game the third is
deep upgrade paths the stronger
connection with each mortal shell grows
the better you can harness your innate
talents recover vulnerable weapons
sharpen your iron with acid and study
devastating arcane powers we already
know some of the arcane powers already
shown in the trailer that being the fire
and ice a OE attacks but for the rest we
didn't see too much of it maybe it'll be
covered later in some future video but
it seems the longer you stick with your
body the more upgrades you can make it
so that it can you know eventually
beefed up and keep track and power level
with other enemies that are you're going
to be fighting and it's gonna be this
constant game of keeping track of what
body you have and what upgrades you have
but also maybe there's a body right next
to you that has a weapon better suited
for the boss that you're fighting so
maybe what do you choose do you want
your fully upgraded body with a decent
weapon or a new body with a really good
weapon against that boss it's gonna make
you constantly think the more you play
this game and then the very last panel
says your path is guarded by desperate
adversaries devoted to inscrutable gods
behold creatures both pitiful and
grotesque but do not let them halt your
journey this is just reference to the
disgusting and giant enemies that we're
bound to be fighting that we've seen in
the trailer I can't wait to see how
these bosses are gonna look and the
diversity between them and I mentioned
before that maybe there is the idea to
eventually possess bosses but maybe it's
not in the sense that I'm thinking now
the more that I keep kind of reading
this stuff going on I don't think that
we're gonna be able to possess the
bodies of the bosses but maybe be able
to use their weapon
kind of like our Dark Souls you can cash
in the you know the soul of sender stuff
and you can get souls and gain some of
their weapons like yours giant hammer
obviously your [ __ ] giant axe or
whatever he happens to be using isn't
that size or also it would be 40 feet
tall so they have a smaller dim down
version for you but it's still his
weapon but honestly that's just my idea
on this I've always been a big fan of
being able to use the bosses weapons in
any game that I play so any option that
I can come up with a theory for it I'll
definitely put it in a video but as for
some other smaller but more important
bits it's confirmed on the website that
it does come out on PC the PlayStation
Store and Xbox and for PC users I know
we have to deal with battlenet origin
you play all that stuff it doesn't
specify so I'm just going to assume
Steam - it's also releasing sometime in
the third quarter of 2020 so predicts
around the summer time and possibly
early September so if you're still in
classes this should be a nice little
summer break opportunity for you to just
sit down and play this game and as well
you could be one of the first people to
play the beta by joining the discord
I'll leave a link to the website
provided down below if you want to check
the link to the dis chords that you
could possibly get a beta code but yeah
that is pretty much everything we know
about mortal shell at the moment the
only thing that wasn't mentioned was
anything PvP or a multiplayer related so
I'm not going to say no just yet but
maybe there is some small PvP in the
game like invasion style stuff but not
some full-blown 5 b 5 fight to the death
TDM kind of thing like shooter games and
other games of that genre have as well
so I'm not gonna knock the points off
for no PvP just yet because maybe they
haven't talked about it but it seems to
be this incredibly unique game that a
lot of people should definitely be on
the lookout for if they're into this
kind of genre with this insanely cool
possessed mechanic a lot of other games
have you know possessing mechanics as
well whether they be skills feats or
something of that nature but but those
games don't have it near as deep as this
does as those games just have it as a
small part of the combat whereas this is
more fleshed out as this is the
literally the main basis of mortal
shells combat system being able to
possess dead corpses and gain their
weapons and knowledge and I know a lot
of people like to point fingers at the
souls like name and obviously that was
huge when crash bandicoot of all games
was given souls like kind of style for
its difficulty
I'm not trying to point fingers at that
but I think it's pretty obvious that a
lot of the combat and stuff while maybe
not directly influenced is very similar
and like I said it's always nice to kind
of give people a reference for
similarities between other games so that
they can you know make it good enough
based decision based off the information
if they do want to purchase that game
and at this moment that's why I want to
keep continuing with the it is a Souls
like game but obviously it's not
directly like that there's a huge amount
of elements of this game which of course
might add are extremely fantastic that
are definitely separating this game from
a traditional Dark Souls Demon Souls
blood-borne type game yeah with that I'm
gonna head off for today guys thank you
guys for coming to the video let me know
what you guys think about this new game
in the comments below is this go is this
right up your alley for games are you
more of like a different style maybe
does this intrigue you does this not
intrigue you anything about this game
definitely let me know in the comments
down below what the guys like to be if
you do enjoy subscribe if you're new or
that take care I'll see you on a future
video and peace out
you
[Music]